- Do you consider yourself
a pretty good dancer?
- I love to dance.
I dance no matter what, I dance.
I dance by my pool.
I dance in my heels.
I dance, you know, like I consider myself,
you know how like
Beyonce has Sasha Fierce?
I've always considered myself,
like I wanted to be a backup dancer
for like Beyonce, or Janet
Jackson, or a Tina Turner.
Oh, that's me!
Girl, I'm over here mopping
the floor, sweeping.
I dance.
I don't play around.
Any time I can dance,
look mopping the floor.
- Look at the slow, the slow
move to the right, the slow-mo.
- I'm telling you-
- [Kelly] I dance around my house.
- Do you dance?
- I dance.
- It's like the best.
- I, I literally, at night
I put my kids to bed,
I put music on sometimes
like a crazy person,
and I will put on some
Florence and Machine,
and I will lose my mind.
- And you lose your mind.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That is the best.
I think it just, it
brings up these endorphins
and you feel good, you feel sexy.
I'm about to get a pole in my house.
Didn't know that, did you, Taylor?
- Oh my God!
- If they gone do the pole?
I sure did.
I'm waiting for Amazon
to deliver that baby.
- Oh my God, Amazon literally
can deliver anything,
can't they?
- Anything!
- Well, you can catch
Sherri, and, and you're going
to want catch her, she's
a lot and I love her.
She's one of my favorite people
I've ever had on the show.
No offense, Taylor, I love you.
But Sherri, you make me
laugh, like, deep down.
I love you so much.
But, you can catch Sherri-
- Taylor, 818-325 (beep).
Make sure you remember that.
- I'm calling.
- This is the greatest
show ever, I love it.